hey everyone i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen I hope you were all
keeping yourself safe and healthy
wherever you are in the world as we're
definitely dealing with some very scary
times now considering the demographic of
people who follow me today I want to
talk about how to manage your
relationship with food during Kovan 19
as this is very likely being tested
right now and you know a lot of you have
asked me for this content in my comment
section now as always my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for education and entertainment
purposes only and is not in any way
intended to prescribe or diagnose so
always reach out and speak to a health
care professional about your unique case
now if you are like me your community is
likely practicing social distancing
right now which means of course working
from home probably at your kitchen table
and close to food all day meanwhile
you're no longer going to your hit or
spin class every day or like ever and
your covin 19:00 panic grocery shop may
have consistent of ice cream chips and
other convenience foods as well as your
access to fresh fruits and vegetables
being limited it's not surprising then
that we've seen an influx of means and
internet jokes about the quarantine 15
or gaining the Cova 19 while we're all
hunkering down now it might seem funny
to joke about gaining a lot of weight as
your way to kind of lighten already not
so bright mood but for people who are
struggling with their relationship with
food and their bodies in general these
are particularly challenging times
now no matter what your normal mental
health status nobody is really immune to
the psychological toll that social
isolation and Quarantine may have a
review published in February and the
Lancet looked at 24 studies to evaluate
the psychological impact of quarantine
and found a number of problematic
outcomes including post-traumatic stress
disorder confusion and anger you know
the major variables involved in people's
experiences include fears around
infection and adequate supplies
financial loss stigma and boredom all of
this is the perfect storm to drive even
people with borderline or people with
relatively normal
with food into the extremes of
restriction and binging but let's talk
specifically about this copán 19 and our
relationship with food so today I want
to chat about some of the major reasons
that we might see our social distancing
efforts perpetuate disordered or
emotional eating for those who are
actively struggling with their
relationship with food those who have
recovered to kind of fall into a relapse
and for the vast majority of people who
have felt even slightly impacted by diet
culture as with this vaccine less
coronavirus nobody is immune reason
number one the perception of scarcity
now we know from research on food
insecurity that the perception of food
scarcity can trigger disordered eating
i've also talked a law on my channel
about the perception of scarcity or
purposeful restriction and how that can
lead to binging or chaotic eating but
even if you're not on a weight-loss diet
or experiencing food insecurity this
whole Coppa 19:00 situation simulates
that experience to a tee in the past we
could go to the grocery store however
often we wanted to get a specific brand
or food item that we really want to eat
we could plan a meal on the fly based on
what we felt like in that moment and if
we didn't feel like cooking we could
very easily order in or go out for a
meal literally within a moment's notice
but we no longer have immediate access
to food that we want and it's getting
stressful Instagram is littered with
images of empty grocery store shelves
grocery delivery orders need to be
placed like a week in advance and
there's no promise that half the things
on your list are gonna be available when
it's your time to shop so whether you've
struggled with an eating disorder in the
past or not this perception of scarcity
or restriction may easily lead us to
compulsively overeat when we do have
food out of anticipatory fear that we
don't know when that chance is coming
again
now reason number two is temporary food
abundance so on the flip side there are
lots of people talking about their epic
food halls and coronavirus snacks and
while a lot of people who struggle with
eating may limit the amount of food in
their home at one time the grocery store
halls that this situation has in sight
may have your pantry and fridge stuff to
the brim this easy access to food
supplies can very easily trigger binge
eating episodes when there's the
constant reminder of the impending food
shortage or lack of access in the back
of our brain
number three lack of access to specialty
diet foods now for those who are
strictly following a really strict keto
diet or Paleo diet or whatever and
relying on specialty foods and
ingredients to maintain that diet it may
be especially stressful to imagine that
this may not be so easy
while in isolation with limited grocery
access you might not be able to get your
specialty low carb high protein bars and
maybe you can't choose the leanest cut
of meat at the store this can be highly
stressful for people reason number four
is no more gym a lot of people use
exercise not just for their mental
sanity but also for those who have a
history disordered eating it may be use
as a way to balance dietary intake with
all of your fitness classes and gyms
closed and most of us feeling really
cooped up in tiny apartments the
inability to exercise and move may spark
massive fear of weight gain which in
turn may perpetuate caloric restriction
number five the excessive food talk as I
mentioned there is a lot of talk about
food right now lack of food in the
grocery stores quarantine snacks gaining
the köppen 19 what to make with canned
lentils etc if you're online and let's
be real what else is there to do right
now you cannot escape the world's
obsession about what to eat and if you
have a history of emotional or
disordered eating this can definitely
set you off number six
being in close quarters with triggering
family now being in close proximity to
family members with no escape or
external outlets can be highly stressful
and triggering for a lot of people often
times it's these close individuals who
may actually have stimulated the
problematic eating in the first place
even if you were to feel like you had
gotten your you know mental health in a
really good place before coronavirus
it's very possible that this could
reignite a lot of problems
number seven stress and emotional eating
as I've discussed on my channel many
times a lot of us turn to food to deal
with negative emotions that's totally
normal and it's totally normal and
common to be turning to food in these
uncertain times for a lot of you it
really may be the only friend we have in
the home but when it becomes our only
coping mechanism
we may see symptoms that range from
severe caloric restriction to total
binge eating and we'll talk more about
that very soon number eight mandated
isolation social isolation in general is
a really common feature of eating
disorders as it makes it easier to avoid
social eating experiences and body
exposure which can make a person more
likely to maintain or fall back and
disorderly behaviors now when people are
in recovery or in therapy they are
literally told not to socially isolate
you know to be as social as possible
when they can but here we are unable to
do anything else but be on our own
and finally the lack of access to
therapy those who are used to getting
regular access to therapy for anxiety
depression and disorderly thoughts may
be no longer able to do that thanks to
social distancing protocol hence why
this is becoming a big problem now to
help everyone during these uncertain
times I had a chat with two different
intuitive eating dietitian colleagues
about their experiences and what they're
telling their patients in tough times
like these I always joined separately by
Ellen Silverman and Jesse Haggerty two
dietitians who work with eating disorder
patients so thank you both so much for
joining me let's take a look at those
interviews tell me a bit about some of
the themes that you're seeing in your
now virtual appointments over the last
week it's really changed at the
beginning of last week most people were
like you know concerned about their were
concerned about you know how are they
going to keep going this week it's kind
of changed to reality like again a lot
of my clients are very food insecure so
they're just like you know they're
sitting at home and here they are
dealing with their eating disorder and
they don't know they're looking in their
cabinets they're looking in the refer
they don't know what to eat and so it's
changed to that you have anything that
I'm noticing is that some clients are
like you know concerned about their not
being able to pay for their visits you
know is it more important we're gonna go
for their therapists or you know go to
their dietician for a virtual visit
that's another running theme and then a
lot of them are having a lot of issues
around isolation so when they're in
isolation their diseases are more
rampant and their voices are hard to
ignore
so that you know their eating disorder
voice comes out loud and proud and
they're not able to fight it and it's
interesting because some of them have
been in really good stable recovery for
a long time and thoughts of like you
know their childhood and not having food
and you know that stuff is coming up
from a deep place that they've already
worked on maybe but now it's coming up
like in a different capacity a lot of my
plans are student that has now gone from
living on campus to living with their
families and they're not in charge of
when they're eating or what they're
eating right now is that can always be
really stressful a lot of my clients
have started working at home all of a
sudden I'm used to working at home my
work time people who are not used to
working at home it can be stressful to
feel like on one hand you have this like
constant access to food in your house
and then on the other hand you're kind
of limited to how often you leave your
house - maybe procure more food I know
that in a lot of areas there are a lot
of grocery stores that have very limited
amounts of food available so yeah it's
pretty stressful no matter what
situation here so how can we eat
intuitively when the food that we have
in our freezer or a pantry is maybe not
what we really want I'd go back to the
hierarchy of needs and nourishment being
one of them and when they're you know
I'm having I'm kind of encouraging them
to plan a little bit but I've had to do
I've had to see what's in my cabinets in
my refrigerator and and kind of look
okay what do I have I have some ground
beef
deep breath I have what do I have and
put together a little meal plan so for
dinner we're gonna have this sort of if
that lasts and just go a few days out
not to think about it too much um I also
have them kind of reevaluate their label
on the foods they don't want to eat like
why do you have that label on it what's
that all about and can we think about it
a little bit differently can you make
something out of those foods that you
have that you don't want to eat can you
make it into something you would e like
you might want so instead of having I
don't know
tuna fish on crackers can you put some
peanut butter and jelly on some crackers
and have a glass of milk can you
scramble up some eggs say I don't feel
like eggs well how about if you stick
some cheese in it and maybe some of that
summer sausage that's in the back of
your refrigerator that can last a long
time
maybe sticking that in it so rethinking
you know the basic reason why they're
not wanting the food and kind of seeing
if we can kind of change it around a
little bit I think that intuitive eating
generally gets this reputation of being
this like eat whatever you want whenever
you want for the work that I do with my
clients I think that it is always very
rooted and first and foremost like
gentleness and self compassion so just
being a little bit kinder to yourself
now knowing that there's never really
such thing as perfect eating but right
now like give yourself permission to do
like a c+ job but I think that the
things that you can focus on are
honoring your hunger making time to eat
throughout the day I mean I typically
recommend clients trying to make space
to eat every three to four hours trying
to get some protein some parts some fat
there's a lot of flexibility that you
can do within those parameters and
especially if you're working from home
like taking breaks to eat and seal
yourself I think that when you don't
have those natural breaks built into
your day with commuting or lunch with
coworkers it can be really difficult to
represent
remember to eat sometimes what are some
your top tips for avoiding falling into
either restrict or bench like tendencies
during these times I am a big person
about self-compassion and self grace and
so again not trying not to beat
themselves over the head during a very
stressful time and letting them know
that we all binge for example like we
all have that tendency to want to do
something that will comfort so no no
judgment on that restriction again I'm
honoring their where they're at I'm
having them acknowledge why they're
there why do they want to restrict what
is it because they're scared they're
gonna run out of food let's acknowledge
that you know oh but then I have them
kind of turn it around and likes and
again some of these clients have had
some tools in their toolbox that they're
not using so I'm like okay let's get
that out let's redirect but I want you
to feel that feeling I don't want you to
push it down so let's talk about it I
have them journals some of these
feelings that are coming out that around
their binging and restricting if they're
still on a meal plan from IOP or you
know in my practice I don't really have
meal plans but I might have to do that I
have to go back to their meal plan for
some security it's a lot of this has to
do with loss of control of which they
already have issues with loss of control
and they have no security when are they
getting groceries how are they gonna get
out to get groceries who's gonna get
groceries for me what am I gonna get
when I get there or are they gonna bring
home when they when they give when I
give a list so again addressing that
these are real concerns not to pooling
them and saying oh it'll be alright for
a lot of us it's not alright yes
knowledge thing that there are there
that we're feeling that too but let's
kind of walk through some of the tools
that you've used in the past to get
through it and and then again having
them take a pause and do some grounding
around meals like if you're really
anxious let's kind of come back to the
meal in a little while and look at it a
little bit differently let's do some
grounding and breathing exercises or
whatever they can do I mean again I
think like first and foremost have
a little bit of gentleness with yourself
around this we're all trying to figure
this out this is not easy for everyone
but again I think really trying to build
in those breaks throughout the day so
every few hours if you're making a
schedule for yourself like building in a
time to like have a snack have something
to eat if you have access to maybe like
more fun foods that you may normally
consider off-limits like making time to
have those foods so they don't feel like
they're in your house but you're also
not allowed to have them like allow
yourself to have the foods that you
enjoy yeah and I think that like I said
before just trying to have a mix having
a variety of foods as much as possible
and I think now even though our options
are more limited it is probably a way to
start adding more variety into your diet
ice maybe you weren't someone who
normally went to the frozen food section
or to the canned food section I know
that there's like so many ways you can
get creative with foods like that we
don't normally think about totally agree
and a lot of us actually get into food
routines and for some people those
routines can be disorderly so for some
this may actually be used to help us
kind of edge into new food experiences
now what other coping strategies can
people use to deal with their anxiety
other than food while we're here in
isolation again you know again in my
practice I teach some grounding and
stress relieving techniques and so they
have a few in their little tool box so
again box breathing coloring you know
journaling taking a little walk outside
and they're you know wherever they can
take a walk but again to acknowledge
that they're feeling these feelings why
what did what feeling is going along
with the wanting to binge or wanting to
emotionally eat if it's sadness or
loneliness or it's isolation that's not
a feeling but you know abandonment what
is that feeling and where's that coming
from
and let's just talk about it I also work
a lot with my therapist and so if I'm
picking up something that's a big
red flags I'm not even a big red flag
red flag I'm texting my therapist that
they are with and letting them know so
that they can check in on them because
sometimes I'll get something before the
therapist will get it and I don't want
it just to sit so I'm really good I have
the core I call them the core of for but
they're not now the core of seven
therapists that I work with and I'm like
all right
client blah blah blah is like talking
like this can you just check on and they
always do they just do a check-in with
them and I'm I'm really blessed to have
wonderful therapist that I work with and
if it's really serious I'm a physician
assistant I will call their doctor or
their psychiatrist and let them know
that they're really kind of you know not
doing well I'm not I'm not afraid to
call other team members and let them
know what's going on we work as a team
so again that's some of the ways I deal
with it but emotionally eating right now
we're all doing it mm-hmm that ice cream
is one of my favorite friends right now
you know with sprinkles on it by the way
I love my rules yeah so again if we can
make sure that our clients know that
we're human and that we have some of the
same things that we can talk about
together I mean I think on one hand it
food is going to feel provide this sense
of safety for us right now I mean you
can tell just by when you go to the
stores there's nothing there people are
stocking up on food because it's we're
human beings and that gives us a sense
of safety so I think allowing food to be
comforting is helpful and then also
having things that are comforting that
are maybe not food-related and I think
the biggest thing that we're probably
all really craving right now is
connection so connecting even with
yourself I would always say like turn
off the news for a little bit
turn off social media maybe do some
reading or journaling if you're into
meditation maybe something like that and
then connecting with other people so
I've been doing a lot I've been on Zoo
family I think just making time to have
like as close of the
today's connections as we can possible
okay thank you so much to both of my
guests I'm gonna be leaving their
contact information in the description
below in case any of you are looking to
connect now ultimately these are really
difficult times for a lot of us and it's
so important that we find ways to
practice self compassion for this
unusual circumstance as well as
self-care so I want to share some of my
personal favorite ways to use this time
in isolation to focus on maintaining our
well-being so number one go for a walk
while chatting with friends on the phone
or FaceTime I mean it might be not as
engaging as your normal hit workout
class but you'll be getting your body
moving some endorphins flowing and
you'll get to catch up with some friends
number to plan a meal like a week in
advance and work in food so you actually
want to eat that you're excited about
so I recommend doing a full week meal
plan including snacks breakfasts lunches
and maybe plan like one extra emergency
meal that's largely coming from the
freezer so something that is like really
super easy like a frozen pizza that way
if the grocery store throws you like a
curveball and they're out of something
that's really important to make a
specific dish on your list then at least
you know you have a backup for that
night that's in your plan number three
grab a cookbook and resolve to make
something new and exciting since we're
all basically already out of our usual
routine this is a really good time to
expand that into our eating routine as
well I've decided to use this as a time
to learn to cook more Asian and Indian
inspired dishes since that is something
that I normally probably would have
eaten out for but I'm really excited to
add that to my weekly repertoire also
Amazon is still shipping cookbooks like
um my mindful glow so grab something new
or slim that's been collecting dust on
your shelf and make something exciting
number four meditate or stretch everyday
so even if you're fully stuck inside
which may be the eventual reality for a
lot of us try to take some time for your
mental health through breathing and
gentle movement there are tons of
amazing apps podcasts and videos on
YouTube that feature some really awesome
meditations and
stretches that will help you manage your
stress and anxiety in these uncertain
times
number five focus on getting a good
night's sleep I know this is easier said
than done
as somebody who struggles with sleep on
a good day but sleep is also imperative
not only for our mental health but also
for our physical health and immune
system you can check out my video here
for some natural remedies that I have
used when I was really in the pits of my
insomnia but if you're still struggling
I think there is no shame in speaking to
your doctor
virtually of course if you can about
taking a sleeping aid even just getting
a solid night's rest after several days
of broken sleep will do wonders for your
coping mechanisms and number six be
compassionate for yourself it is normal
to be struggling with emotional eating
in these times where we are all so
emotional right there's so many emotions
to be had the biggest thing I want you
to take away is that it's completely
normal for you to be struggling right
now and you're not failing for using
food to cope with your emotions a lot of
us use food to cope with our emotions
and there are a lot of emotions going on
right now so my recommendation for you
is to acknowledge it and try to pivot
where you can some of the awesome coping
strategies that we talked about today
and if you're finding that these coping
strategies and tools are just not giving
you the support that you need to help
you deal with your emotions and
therefore you're turning exclusively to
food for that this may be a time for you
to reach out virtually of course to a
therapist or psychologist for a little
bit of help so folks that is all for
today I hope this video was kind of
inspiring and helping you to manage and
cope with some of your anxiety around
food during these really scary and
uncertain times as always please don't
forget to give me the thumbs up leave me
a comment below on what kind of content
you'd like to see more of do you want to
see more Kovach content or do you prefer
to keep yourself distracted with more of
my usual what I eat in a day reviews of
course also subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]